[Música]
de forma pacífica y con lemas en favor
de la democracia miles de personas se
manifestaron contra el golpe militar del
1 de febrero en mianmar en las que hasta
la fecha han sido las mayores protestas
la dictadura militar no se ajusta a
ninguna ley los militares tomaron el
poder del estado injustamente no
respetaron el voto del pueblo y creo que
están traicionando el país lucharemos
hasta el último minuto y nuestra
revolución ha comenzado muchos
ciudadanos están hartos del poder que
sigue ejerciendo la cúpula militar sobre
la política del país durante la jornada
se han sumado diferentes colectivos a
las protestas como el sector obrero los
abogados los médicos o los profesores
seis días después del levantamiento las
principales figuras políticas del país
siguen detenidas incluyendo a la líder a
un sándwich y las reivindicaciones
siguieron hasta la noche donde muchos
quemaron imágenes de los representantes
militares el ejército decidió entonces
cortar los servicios de internet y
telefonía para evitar la propagación de
lo que llaman noticias falsas este chat
de internet desde que cerraron internet
no sabemos qué está pasando realmente ni
al mar así que creo que están
protestando en la calle
vi a algunas fotos a través de cuentas
de redes sociales y lo están haciendo
pacíficamente nadie es violento
y hasta 2010 me amar sufrió décadas de
dictaduras militares persecución de
opositores y violación de derechos
humanos algo que muchos temen que
regrese junto con el bloqueo de la
comunidad internacional